if you're looking for ways to find your
gift be confident and focus then this
video is for you at one point he played
ten chess players at the same time
looking the other way so we couldn't do
the board I've never been the one to to
grasp things the quickest but I've never
stopped learning as soon as I became
interested in in subject is that I have
the confidence to make decisions that
are slightly unorthodox need motivation
watch top ten would believe nation
what's up it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
in that amazing gift you have inside you
that I want to see come out so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from playing chess at age five with a
goal to beat his elder sister to
becoming a chess grandmaster at age
thirteen and later a world chess
champion
he's Magnus Carlsen and here's my take
on his top ten rules to success
alright let's kick it off with rule
number one find your gift he did have
some special crates orderly oh yeah ton
of the army research we do show Gary
Kasparov was ranked number one in the
world which is blue add in peloton
[Applause]
yeah you walk normally right miss mr.
[Music]
Porteous on forensics we're sex thrown
the AFM much more near drowning yell
tonight what he's called the Mozart of
chess and I can see it
you couldn't understand how Mozart did
what he did it came from another world
and magnus carlsen is doing things that
no human being I've met before can do at
one point he played ten chess players at
the same time looking the other way so
we couldn't see the board boy um yeah I
mean just think about it
ten chess boards that he has in his mind
every second were sex the mantra doesn't
lose track of what's happening on the
boards and what he needs to do next
boyfriend Amida can you explain what was
going on in your head really I was just
focusing focusing on trying to remember
the positions and from time to time I
had to think a little bit to come up
with a good move as well even he admits
that it's not easy I would wonder where
a certain pieces and so I had you know
replay the game in my in my head from
from the very beginning how long did it
take you to do that I don't know half a
minute or something [ __ ] I ultra it
will be interesting to try like 20
people have you ever done that
no ten is the most I've done and you
could you'd like to try more it would be
fun I love this clip and I'm a big
believer that everybody has Michael
Jordan level talent or magnus carlsen
level talent at something he is great at
playing chess but he probably sucks at
almost everything else meanwhile you are
great as something to you are magnus
carlsen level talent at something go
all-in on that that's where you're going
to win
goto rule number two pursue your dreams
at what point did you decide to become a
professional chess player and to really
focus on playing chess for a living I
really only decided that towards the end
of high school before that my parents
had brainwashed me into thinking that I
should pursue a higher education and I
thought that was I thought I was
reasonable
generally reasonable yes yeah yes but at
that point I was not so interested in in
school and I was doing very well at
chess and I was already making some
money and then it made perfect sense for
me to to to be a professional and see
how far I could reach so he decided
early on in high school that he was
gonna live his version of his life right
and when you can break free of the
shackles of your parents your community
and your peer group and their
expectations of you and say I'm living
my version of my life instead of your
version of my life that's when you start
to win let's jump to rule number three
focus what kind of talent I had from
when I was very young was that I was
able to concentrate on something for a
long time and that my interest in
something didn't kind of didn't really
wane and I I just kept on kept on
learning and I think that's been you
know my main advantage focus yeah focus
on the fact that I don't stop learning
I'm not I'm not
I never been the one to to grasp things
the quickest but I've never stopped
learning as soon as I became interested
in the subject what I find really
interesting is he said he's not the
fastest learner but because he kept at
it and he focused and he persevered he
won and it's the same thing for whatever
you want to get into there will be
people who will be more naturally
talented than you but if you keep at it
if you keep working hard you keep
focusing you
gonna be the one who wins moving out of
rule number four be confident I mean
confidence is a huge part of chess
that's part of what what makes me the
best right now is that I have the
confidence to make decisions that are
slightly unorthodox or or controversial
because I have belief in my ability to
figure those things out over the board
while others might consider those same
things but be more apprehensive just
watching them play that quickly leads me
and on like the talent that they have
how much perseverance and hard work they
put in to be able to go that quickly and
think that fast I love it I think for
confidence it really just comes down to
leading with your heart when you have
that feeling that you want to go off and
do something when you have that thing in
your head that I feel like I should try
that you practice actually trying and
you're not gonna win every time but
you're gonna win more often than not and
if you train yourself to whenever you
get a crazy idea that you want to try
not to do it then what you've done is
train yourself to play small and not be
confident instead of what you want to do
just chase your dreams all right time
for rule number five learn from the
Masters as you were becoming a
grandmaster and then later as a teenager
were there any particular chess players
you really looked up to are there any of
any former world champions that you feel
you've learned the most from or I really
liked the games of Kramnik when I when I
was young I I got a book of his games
when I was about 11 and I really learned
a lot from from those games and I
learned from many others as well but it
was really not in my it's written never
really been in my style according to my
philosophy to to idolize play
to try to copy them I just trying to
learn and get the best from the great
masters comtemporary
and and from the past it's it's like
that for me in everything I I don't
really idolized people too much but I
try to learn from what they do success
leaves clues I named this channel model
the Masters because whatever you want to
do there's somebody who's already done
it who's figured it out and if you can
model a little bit of what works for
them and apply to your life to your
business you can really shook out your
path to success as well alright time for
rule number six practice I would like to
talk about how you handle the
preparation in the weeks and months
before a major competition what do you
do how do you get ready for that kind of
event well first of all I think the only
I mean what's most important of all this
is to is to you know practice by by
playing actual playing actual games of
chess because I mean you can you can
work for four six months have be
wonderfully prepared for the openings
have plenty of new ideas solve all the
tactical exercises you know be in the
best shape of your life but still if you
you know if you haven't if you're out of
playing training then you will still be
be rusty so that is that is important
and you do more of that the closer you
get to competition yeah exactly so like
for the last World Championship match
four months in advance we would work on
new ideas and everything but then when
we got closer it was more about about
playing I mean I I played you know
thousands of of training games in that
period what I loved really seen from
people to talk with their game like
Magnus
is they have the natural talent they had
the natural inclination growing up but
they work so hard to get to the top and
even once they're at the top they work
hard and hard and hard and practice and
practice and practice thousands of games
to prepare for one final World
Championship and so whatever it is that
you want to do you kind of just put in
the work the quantity leads to the
quality I promise
practice practice practice all right up
next rule number seven find your
motivation it's not only about being the
champion it's also about you know being
number one in rankings winning
tournaments and and so on and that is
definitely a hard to to maintain it's
one thing to do it one year it's another
to do it several years and unfortunately
this year I haven't been able to do it I
I've had I still have a couple more
chances to do well but it hasn't been
been great so far and that's one of my
motivations for for for the next year to
sort of regain the status as an
undisputed number number one and yeah
but you see it in every sport like
people who reach reach the top they they
always struggled to maintain it for for
many reasons I mean but mainly because
the opponents are becoming stronger and
they might even be be hungrier so that's
that's going to be a challenge for you
for me this just speaks to the
importance of having goals when you have
a clear goal of something that you want
to accomplish you'll work harder towards
achieving that goal where if your goal
is just I want to work as hard as I can
you never actually work as hard as you
can you never actually create the best
products you can you ever create the
best experience that you can but when
you have a goal when you have our target
that I want to hit this thing by next
year then you work harder towards
achieving it every single day so have
important goals for your life and your
business let's jump to rule number eight
analyze your losses you learn the most
from games you lose or games you win
is there anything you can generalize
about that I think over time I probably
learned more from games I lose I'm
usually and who's that pushes you to
really think about why you lost and what
you should have done differently yeah
but usually what whenever I lose at
least before I I thought I had a pretty
good idea whether what I've done wrong
and I usually thought it was a concrete
mistake that was my undoing
but over time I think I realized that
probably there was something more
profound there that I actually made more
mistakes than I thought I had and I
evaluated some position mistakenly and
so on so I think over time you your
definitely learn more from your losses
even if you're someone like me who
doesn't like to go that the old Soviet
style of painstakingly analyzing your
losses I think over time you learn from
them anyway I think this is just another
example of someone who's super
successful who sees failure as something
different than what most people see most
people think failure is this final thing
that's a reflection of yourself that now
you suck you tried your thing it didn't
work out you failed now you are a
failure where no successful people fail
all the time and that's what you learn
that's what you grow it's not like you
are seeking failure out and you want to
feel all the time but when you do fail
you use it as a chance to grow it
doesn't mean that you suck as a human
being that you're never gonna win again
you use it to learn how to do your thing
better and that's a huge mindset shift
between the people who have a lot of
success and the people who don't alright
next is rule number 9 yoga and meditate
how else do you keep yourself in peak
mental and physical condition do you do
yoga do you meditate for example yeah I
did I did yoga for for a while I haven't
really meditated much
in general I'd like to to be to be
active so I do that for fun and it helps
it helps my chess so so that's that's a
good good thing I think I think I should
do more meditation because the few times
I've done it I don't know if I've shown
better results but it definitely helped
my mind maybe clearer I always love
hearing people talk about yoga
meditation because I don't do it and I
haven't felt the benefit from it I've
tried a lot of different times and every
time I hear it against like I kind of
try again I got to find the right model
I got to keep on until I find the way
that it clicks for me if you guys have
any resources share around yoga or
meditation that I need to try that's
worked insanely well for you leaving the
comments below because I would love to
have it work for me too
alright and the final rule before
getting to the bonuses rule number ten
is be a champion Mongoose is ranked
number seven hundred in the world and
Kasparov is ranked number one there are
28 years separating the two this is an
historic moment cuz Pato has never
played against anyone this young
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Magnus is leading by one porn but he
doesn't have much time left
[Music]
[Applause]
ah Joe it's a sensation
Magnus managed to jorgens kobato
Kasparov couldn't beat Magnus that was a
fun clip to watch I thought he was gonna
win though I thought at the end of it he
was gonna win but I guess the draw as a
kid against the world champion is is
awesome I loved also watching that
little pregame rituals of you sit down
you have to touch all the pieces and
touch the board and all that really
speaks to having a routine that gets you
set up for success before you step into
doing whatever you're about to do
so that's my take on his top ten roots a
success I would say rule number one find
your gift is my favorite I just love the
idea that everybody has that unique gift
inside them that if you figure out what
it is and you go all-in on that instead
of trying to live up to somebody else's
expectations that's when you actually
start to win I'd love to know what your
favorite rule was was the number one
with mine or with this one that you felt
is better than number one more
applicable to your life that you're
going to take some immediate action on
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out now I made
this video because 10 deal asked me to
if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you are made of profound X check out the
link in the description you can go to
that request line and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Reverend Steve Harris from the
restoration house thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my new book the top
ten rules a success and posting that
review to Amazon with the picture and
everything I love a man thank you so
much for the support I hope you enjoyed
the book so thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is
much love see you soon
for me the most important thing was
what's the passion to learn to have fun
obviously to win but most of all to
learn and growing up I was I still am
but I was pretty used to doing basically
the things I wanted to do and most of
the time that that was chess and so I
would constantly be sitting at my my
board reading some chess books playing
online playing tournaments whenever I
could and I think to become really good
at chess you need you know you really
need that to become to become one of the
best it's it's not enough to to go to
the Chess Club a few times a week play a
tournament now and then as you would
another sport you shouldn't just go to
to practice you should also you should
be in a sense living chess yeah all the
time yes
so what are you doing for the rest of
the day I'm preparing for the next game
he had a day off he'd been in London
before but told us he'd never seen the
sights we took him up onto this it's a
giant Ferris wheel that overlooks London
and it's right on the south side of the
Thames so you can see the houses of
parliament Big Ben we were up in the
London Eye for I guess 45 minutes so he
didn't look at the window just she
wasn't interested do you ever stop
thinking about chess sometimes but right
now I was actually thinking about chess
and you were thinking about specific
moves yeah I was thinking about
something specific in my preparation for
my game tomorrow you drew the comparison
to athletes do you think of yourself as
an athlete well I'm I I do think so or
or a sports person at least I mean I I
strive first and foremost to to achieve
good results when I when I when I sit
down at the chess board some people view
chess as an art it for me definitely can
be an art but all of that you know it's
second is secondary to to winning which
is which is the main goal and what I
what I do in preparation for tournaments
what I do during tournaments it's all
about achieving achieving the best
result possible raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
that people passion and not one drop of
my self-worth depends on your it's
supposed to me I don't ever give up I'd
have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
rows of success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link the
description for details